Oprah Winfrey zwei – diese Ayanna
Huffington, diese Meg. Ryan und Angelina
Jolie in Falls und alle Steve Jobs,
Siddhartha Xuan haben großartige Medici,
am zehnten die Ochsen, Kaito Dada,
Achtsamkeit,
East Austin, Pfeifen, Angst, Englisch,
galant alhamdulillah, die
Wände würden bei englischen Medici-Kräutern sprechen  und
Koriander erfreuen sich an John Kabat-Zinn,
sie sind die fantastischen Kite-Funken,
Investment-Elternteil, Kmart entscheiden sich, ob ome
Sierra sehen, wie es ein Bomber im Studio ist.
East hat kleine Kommentare zu Coverton
oft nicht gesehen, wie es gezeigt wird,
meditieren Sie wissen, dass dies eine Art
ungewöhnliche Frage in dem Sinne ist, dass Sie, wenn
Sie wirklich in die Meditationspraxis einsteigen
, sehr schnell
erkennen, dass es nicht nur darum geht
, sich tagsüber Zeit zu nehmen  formell zu
meditieren, aber es geht mehr darum, wie du
in Beziehung zu der gesamten
Entfaltung deines Lebens stehst, damit das Leben
selbst wirklich zur Meditation wird
nach einer Weile aktiv sein und nicht nur im Schneidersitz wie
eine Statue im Britischen
Museum sitzen, wirklich ein super warmes
Gericht, oh, natürlich mache ich das, aber
ich halte das dann nicht mehr für die
eigentliche Meditation  in einem
Flugzeug und Sie wissen, dass Sie sich dessen bewusst sind, während
ich ins Studio fahre, um dieses
Interview mit Ihnen zu führen und so weiter. Aus
meiner Sicht ist sogar dieses
Gespräch eine Form der Meditation
Wunsch Ost
Achtsamkeit getan ist interessant Senior
Boom ein bestehender Teilnehmer Versuch Statik im
Jahr Zeichentrickvideo Jack Elliott von
Karen Wilson spezieller Name Chinesischer Fernsehzeichentrickfilm
hier ist in seiner finanziellen
Hinsicht die ultimativen menschlichen Bedürfnisse, die als nächstes wahrgenommen werden,
also ist dies dies als Ernährung,
ja, das ist es nicht  es ist das ist
es mit anderen Worten, dieser Moment, was auch immer sich
entfaltet, ist die Wirklichkeit des gelebten Lebens, es
ist die eigene Erfahrung, wie sich das Leben entfaltet, also ist
die Frage, ob Sie dafür überhaupt hier
sind oder sind Sie es  Sie suchen nach einer besonderen
Erfahrung, die passiert, einer
meditativen Erfahrung, ohne zu
erkennen, dass gerade dieser Moment
unglaublich besonders ist, nur die Tatsache, dass ich
meinen Mund und meine Zunge bewegen kann und Sie
verstehen, was ich sage,
und meine Augen arbeiten, meine Ohren arbeiten Ihre  Augen
arbeiten, deine Ohren arbeiten, das ist wunderbar
und wir können es sehr leicht ignorieren, also bedeutet
Achtsamkeit im Grunde, dass jeder
Moment unglaublich besonders ist, sodass wir
einander nicht vorziehen müssen, aber
es ist mehr die Frage, wie
wir in Beziehung zueinander stehen werden  die angenehmen
Momente die unangenehmen Momente und die
Momente, die weder das eine noch das andere sind und so sehr
leicht zu übersehen sind. Oft sind es die Momente der Initiative
oder nicht, die so konstant sind. Ja,
unsere beiden Lieblingsorte zum Verweilen,
wenn Sie so wollen, sind die Vergangenheit in Erinnerung und
all diese Gedanken darüber  die Vergangenheit und
warum die Dinge auf die eine oder andere Weise passiert
sind und normalerweise auch, wer schuld ist, und
dann die Zukunft mit Sorgen und
Planung, und Sie wissen, das ist perfekt  Ganz
gut, so ist der Verstand eben. Wenn
wir uns die Zukunft nicht vorstellen könnten,
wären wir keine Menschen, und wenn wir uns nicht
an die Vergangenheit erinnern könnten, wären
wir völlig dysfunktional, aber wenn Sie
in der Zukunft vollständig in der Vergangenheit aufgehen
Ohne Bewusstsein wird der gegenwärtige
Moment, der der einzige ist, der überall
lebendig ist, ein wenig gequetscht und
beeinflusst dann die Qualität unseres
Lebens und die Qualität unserer Gesundheit und
so weiter
ein enormer Boom an Dynamik und von
Amazon diese Lehre über Achtsamkeit
Ich bekomme aus Angst ein Trinkgeld für Gesundheit
2012 Ich habe die Zukunft übersprungen Kurs übersprungen Ich habe den
heutigen Tag übersprungen und
ein Feldspieler aus den Städten der Notaufnahme beißt
Van Haaren siehe Jon kabat-zinn
Sehen Sie sich wirklich die Invasion der letzten Zeit an Sadarski
Trade Nam.
Lassen Sie mich zuerst sagen, dass ich denke, dass
es viele, viele verschiedene Strömungen und viele,
viele verschiedene Menschen gibt,
die zu dieser Blüte der Achtsamkeit beitragen, wenn Sie so
wollen  in der
Mainstream-Welt, also bin ich es nicht einfach,
aber ich möchte sagen, dass es meine Absicht war
, dies vor vielen Jahren zu erreichen, als
ich zum ersten Mal die auf Achtsamkeit
basierende Stressreduktionsklinik am
University of Massachusetts Medical
Center gründete, und die Hoffnung war, dass dies der Fall wäre  Wir könnten
einen Weg finden, Meditation und
insbesondere Achtsamkeitsmeditation
für Amerikaner, die unter Stressschmerzen,
chronischen Krankheiten
und so weiter litten, wirklich vernünftig zu machen, dass es wie
ein Lauffeuer losgehen würde, weil es so viel
Leid auf der Welt gibt und wir immer
suchen  Reparaturen außerhalb von uns selbst
, um alles besser zu machen oder alles verschwinden zu lassen,
und dies ist eine Möglichkeit, sich
mit Ihrer eigenen Erfahrung des Guten,
des Schlechten und des Hässlichen anzufreunden und in einer klügeren
Beziehung dazu zu stehen und daher
in gewisser Weise in der Lage zu sein, damit umzugehen
Höhen und
Tiefen eines Lebens, das mit voller Bewusstheit und
einem gewissen Maß an Gleichmut und
Selbstmitgefühl gelebt wird, verschwinden mirin vag  ue für Stella
seufzt Ich schätze, meine Interessen und Molekularbiologie-
Studium am MIT
Anton würden nicht schwer und die Studenten
in diesem Tier in Fiat interessierten
sich für Meditation, es kann nicht bald gut beginnen. Ich
ging 1965 zufällig zu einer Vorlesung von
jemandem namens  Philip Kaplow, der
Reporter bei den Nürnberger Kriegsprozessen war und
später im Winter eiskalt in ein Kloster
in
Hokkaido, Japan, ging
und Zen-Meditation lernte,
sagte unter anderem, dass sich
sein Leben komplett verändert habe und
er an Geschwüren leide  und alle
möglichen stressbedingten Probleme und innerhalb von
sechs Monaten nach der Meditation in einem
eiskalten Kloster verschwanden all diese
Probleme und ich war etwa 21 oder 22 Jahre alt und
als ich mir das anhörte, wurde mir einfach klar, dass dies etwas war, wonach ich gesucht hatte
Das ganze Leben ist in gewisser Weise darauf ausgerichtet,
das wissenschaftliche Verständnis des
Körpers und der Biologie und der Gesundheit mit einer
Art künstlerischem Verständnis der
Schönheit des Lebens und der vielen Unterschiede zu vereinen  Diese
Art und Weise, wie sich dies ausdrückt, begann
1965 von diesem Zeitpunkt an zu meditieren,
und es war so bedeutsam für mich, dass ich einfach
nie aufhörte.
Es sollte nicht täuschen, schnelle technische Crews zu täuschen,
es sagt mir, dass Fotos nicht mehr
vage lackieren. Ich werde das Gefühl haben, dass die Vita
Foundation in diesen Anzeigen nachgelassen hat
, um mich Tolson und Amin zu sehen, und dafür,
dass diese Tat heute passiert,
rettet Malcolm Viet Hashanah  über Lieder in
Ordnung,
behalte alle anderen Seiten, die du kennst, es stellte
eigentlich nicht viele
Hindernisse oder Herausforderungen dar.
Ich denke, Ärzte wissen auf eine bestimmte Weise
, dass sie ihren
Patienten nur bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt helfen können und dass
dies der Fall wäre  viel besser sein, wenn die Menschen in
gewissem Sinne bei ihrer laufenden
Gesundheitsfürsorge und beim Übergang zu einem
höheren Maß an Gesundheit und Wohlbefinden zusammenarbeiten würden,
und es gibt viele verschiedene wirksame
Möglichkeiten, dies zu tun  seine Biologie
und seine Physiologie transformieren, und seit
ich als Molekularbiologe im
Labor eines Nobelpreisträgers am MIT ausgebildet wurde
, projizierten die Leute auf mich, dass ich
wissen muss, was ich tue, also ließen sie
es mich tun und dann ihre  Die
Patienten gingen zu ihnen zurück und sagten Dinge
wie Sie wissen, dass das achtwöchige
MBSR-Programm in acht Wochen mehr
für mich getan hat, als Sie in acht Jahren meine medizinische Situation für mich getan haben,
und die Ärzte haben erkannt,
dass dies etwas wirklich
Wertvolles ist  sozusagen
unter dem dach der medizin und
medizinischen versorgung, um patienten zu befähigen
, sich über die
gesamte
lebensspanne an ihrer eigenen gesundheit und ihrem wohlergehen zu beteiligen
Fall nach der
Anästhesie Hören Sie sich eine Anmerkung
an, um die Meditation in der modernen
jüngsten Welle hier an Stan Scottish
Hidden Estudian in Dänemark als Einwohner zu entlassen
, der in die Entscheidungsverwaltung geführt wurde
Kopfsteinpflaster gelehrt zu erholen und Athener kann sich
morgen von hier aus drehen,
um Tarantino McCarten Ren neu zu bewerten, der
als Erwachsenenmagazin
gegen Tata ausgestrahlt wurde. Er erfindet eine
Meditation unter dem Zauber seiner
Sehun stärksten Handwerker
la ist diese sichtlich
große Demontage zu bestimmten körperlichen Problemen
Bosheit Neid nein zu Visionswelle ist ein
Spieler und Gespräch psyched alle
Ukrainer Ich denke, das ist es, was
diese ganze Bewegung antreibt, die in der
Mainstream-Welt an Achtsamkeit und
an Meditation im Allgemeinen interessiert ist und das ist
dass immer mehr Wissenschaft
dazu gebracht wird und es sehr, sehr
überzeugend ist, und was Sie dort bei
reifer Meditation sehen, ist ein Beispiel für das, was
wir Neuroplastizität nennen, mit anderen Worten,
dass das Gehirn selbst ein sehr plastisches
Organ der Erfahrung ist und sich daher verändert
nicht nur seine Aktivität, sondern auch seine eigentliche
Struktur auf der Grundlage von sich wiederholenden
Aktivitäten der einen oder anderen Art und meiner
Meditation  ation ist eine sich sehr wiederholende Aktivität,
und einige Leute denken vielleicht zuerst,
dass es sehr langweilig ist, weil man
immer wieder dasselbe tut,
aber nach einer Weile merkt man, dass der
gegenwärtige Moment nichts
Interessanteres ist als der gegenwärtige
Moment  Sobald sich die Wissenschaft zu entwickeln begann,
womit ich 1979 begann, war es
für die Leute sehr schwer zu argumentieren, dass
dies nicht wertvoll sei, weil wir nicht
nur die anekdotischen Beweise von medizinischen
Patienten mit vielen verschiedenen chronischen
Diagnosen hatten, sondern auch die wissenschaftlichen
objektivere Erkenntnisse, dass dies
tatsächlich Ihre Physiologie
und Ihr Gehirn und Ihre
Architektur und Struktur transformiert, und wir
wissen jetzt auch, was wir damals durch
die Wissenschaft der sogenannten That-Beat-
Genetik nicht wussten, dass es tatsächlich
die Expression der Gene in Ihnen verändert
Chromosomen und nicht perkoliert und
reguliert Hunderte, wenn nicht Tausende
verschiedener Gene herunter, die für
Krebs bei Infla verantwortlich sind  matory Antworten und alle
möglichen Dinge wie das kann mr gesehen werden
.  Verwenden Sie Süßigkeiten nicht bemerken und nach einer
Muschel ist dies episch Anita Shafer und die
Frau wieder in Kanada Schmidty Tots
Union Ja, niemand weiß wirklich, wie
es durch Meditation beeinflusst werden kann,
aber und es ist nicht nur Meditation, ich bin mir
sicher, dass es viele verschiedene gibt  dinge
einschließlich ernährung wie viel schlaf du bekommst
wie tief deine beziehungen zu
anderen menschen sind was wir verstehen ist,
dass die biologie unserer eigenen
menschheit sehr komplex ist und sehr wechselseitig miteinander verbunden ist
und wenn du zum beispiel
stille und gleichmut kultivierst,
hat sie das
Wir wissen nicht genau, was
der Mechanismus dafür ist, aber wir wissen
bereits genug, um zu wissen, dass dies
wichtig ist und dass wir
es viel viel mehr untersuchen sollten. Ich habe a  Studie aus
den späten 90er Jahren, die zeigte, dass
man Menschen mit Psoriasis, einer
Hautkrankheit, bei der man sehen kann,
was mit ihrer Haut los ist, bei
jungen Menschen vornimmt und sie in eine
Ultraviolett-Lichtbox steckt  Lichtbox werden sie
besser, das nennt man Phototherapie, aber
wenn Sie meditieren, während sie
in der Lichtbox sind, heilen sie
viermal schneller, ihre Haut klärt sich
viermal schneller als Menschen, die nur die
Lichtbehandlung von selbst erhielten, also  Es gibt
etwas, das der Verstand tut,
das den Körper bis hinunter zur Ebene
der Genexpression beeinflussen kann, worum es bei der
Epigenetik geht, und Zellteilung und solche
Dinge,
und dann gibt es auch die interessanten
Daten über das Altern, denn am Ende von
allem von uns  Chromosomen sind diese
Strukturen, die DNA-Sequenzen wiederholen, die
Telomere genannt werden, und die Telomere scheinen
länger zu werden, wenn Sie meditieren, und wenn Sie
unter viel Stress stehen, werden sie kürzer
und kürzer, und wenn Sie Ihre Telomere verlieren, hören
Ihre Zellen auf, sich zu teilen,
und das ist eine Art von  Die biologischen
Signaturen des Alterns und sogar der Ernteeinschnitte, die
die Sixtinischen Lloyd-Forscher in
einer weiterentwickelten verzierten Tomba
zu einem hohen Webstuhl über Handvoll
Miraval machen  le noch
mal Aktivistin miau-miau in andron / - passt noch besser zu unserer Tea Party the song
stones Ich bin glücklich ich würde nicht sagen ich bin
stolz darauf weil ich es nicht als eine
Art individuelle Leistung sehe was
Ich bin sehr glücklich darüber, dass es so
viel Leid auf der Welt gibt und vieles
davon durch unseren eigenen Verstand und
unseren eigenen Lebensstil und durch die Art und Weise, wie wir
miteinander umgehen, geschaffen wird, und wenn wir
dafür immer überzeugendere Beweise entwickeln
können  Wege sind, wie wir
unser eigenes Leben und unsere eigene Gesellschaft so
in die Hand nehmen können, dass Leiden und Schaden minimiert und
Wohlbefinden, Gesundheit, Weisheit und Mitgefühl optimiert werden,
dann ist es fast
selbstverständlich, dass wir uns
mehr in diese Richtung bewegen würden, und ich denke  Die
Beweise an diesem Punkt sind tiefgreifend und
vielleicht sogar überwältigend, dass dies eine
Fähigkeit ist, die uns als Menschen angeboren ist,
und wenn wir sie kultivieren
würden, würden wir tatsächlich zurückfordern oder vielleicht
zum ersten Mal verkörpern, was wir wirklich
meinen, wenn wir  Rufen Sie uns an  ves Homo sapiens
sapiens, nämlich die Spezies, die weiß
und weiß, dass sie es weiß, oder die Spezies
, die sich bewusst ist und weiß, dass sie sich bewusst ist,
und das ist tiefgreifend. Wir nennen
uns seit über hundert Jahren so,
aber ich denke, jetzt haben wir wirklich das
Potenzial dazu  Verkörpern Sie es und erzeugen Sie in
dieser Ära eine Art neue Renaissance,
die wirklich all den
Schaden und den Terror reduzieren könnte, der
in verschiedenen
Ländern und Gesellschaften verbreitet wird, der wirklich
zu enormem Leid und Wahnsinn führt,
wenn Sie Ubuntu installieren  Hudsonville Indy
Survey Estates gibt es einige Drachen
ehrliches Jahr Programm Cynthia Katana
fordert mich heraus
Das I-Element entkam beim Körperscan in
Diamant in Kupfer Ehrfürchtiger Bo
bellte Skippin Yoshida an - hey yo
Kaibaman bald eingeschüchtert und in Altimas Mann -
Abstand vor kurzem neue Kanalisation Thailand und
interesse an diesem dorama so mister of
iron last shop verkauf barroso und kooskia
marketing industrie mr.  Barroso Papst Ian
Eastman Bosch untersucht außerdem alle
Nischen
Ich bin Tau Ik Sohn an der Spitze
ist Sauerorangenlinie Lebensmittel heißt Sohn und das ist
in meinem Namen Lebensmittel und ich bin
sündig Testosteron als Vitamine ist
Talent aus dem Zellkörper Stan Sillas
Mishka  [ __ ], es ist ein süßer, knuspriger Klang,
wenn man es so ausdrückt, nein, es ist überhaupt nicht
gesund, aber hier geht es nicht um
Distanz, sondern um das,
was man Nicht-Anhaftung nennen könnte
Unterschied
zwischen Losgelöstheit, die
Trennung schafft, und
Anhaftung, die klar sieht
und den gesamten Raum Ihrer
Erfahrung und Ihrer Beziehung
festhält, um innerlich und äußerlich zu erfahren, also
geht es hier nicht um Trennung, sondern
in gewissem Sinne um eine gigantische
Umarmung der Wirklichkeit der Dinge  und dass der
Körperscan eine Tür zu meditativen
Erfahrungen ist, das achtsame Yoga eine andere
Tür ist und die Sitzmeditation oder
Gehmeditation oder das Essen von Medi  tation
könnte man sagen, dass es in erster
Näherung alle verschiedenen
Türen in denselben Raum gab, also sind es alle
Formen der Achtsamkeit und sie sind alle
Formen der formalen Meditation, und dann, wie ich
am Anfang sagte, ist die wirklich
wesentliche Form der Meditation  wie du
dein Leben lebst, einen Moment, einen Moment, also
schaust du mich an, ich schaue dich an, während wir uns unterhalten,
gibt es eine gewisse Art
von Bewusstsein, dass
du offensichtlich darüber nachdenkst, was
die nächste Frage sein könnte, aber auch
zuhörst  Was ich jetzt sage, wenn wir
das im Bewusstsein halten, das ist
Achtsamkeit, wenn du nicht achtsam
bist, dann verlierst du eine bestimmte Art von Faden oder
vergisst, was du wirklich fragen wolltest oder so
etwas, und wir könnten auch
gegeneinander reden  -Zwecke, bei denen
wir uns nicht wirklich hören und darauf
reagieren, morgen zu sterben, und daher
Interessen und Unterstützung durch anständige Körper
können, können dies auch Zärtlichkeiten sein, die
oft ins Gesicht
gelaufen sind  ices
me thomas prima Positas ich sie englisch
larson dim ond und artiste ist die schwester
wunde über cannabis bei der auskultation ein
freund und künstler von prema Venetia
mashallah aus konkani smidge panel
darüber, dass der staat den stahl braucht,
ist amerika zwei
monate lang gut gerutscht  der Menschen, die zu MBSR in
die Stressreduktionsklinik kommen, haben
Probleme mit dem Schlaf, weil er eines
der ersten Dinge ist, die gehen, wenn Sie
wirklich gestresst sind oder emotionale Schmerzen
oder chronische körperliche Schmerzen oder was auch immer haben, also
mache ich normalerweise einen Deal mit den Leuten in  Die
Stressreduktionsklinik Ich sage, es ist in Ordnung,
wenn Sie
die geführte Body-Scan-Meditation verwenden, um
nachts einzuschlafen, solange Sie sie zu
einer anderen Zeit während des Tages verwenden, um
aufzuwachen. Die eigentliche Herausforderung besteht also darin, zu
lernen, wie man aufwacht  als
nur einzuschlafen, aber Sie haben recht,
wir leiden alle sehr unter Schlafentzug, also ist es
wichtig, eine gewisse Art von
tiefer Ruhe zu entwickeln, aber die tiefste Ruhe ist
eigentlich, wenn Sie in den Wachzustand fallen
ohne eine Agenda und Sie haben vorhin erwähnt
, nicht zu werten, jetzt wird jeder
, der dies versucht,
fast sofort erkennen, dass es praktisch
unmöglich ist, nicht zu urteilen
Nicht wertend bedeutet nicht, dass
Sie keine Urteile haben werden, es bedeutet, dass
Sie sich dessen bewusst sein werden, wie wertend Sie
normalerweise sind, und dies dann nicht beurteilen, also
versuchen Sie, die Gewohnheit
des Beurteilens und Vorliebens und Abneigungens und der
Entwicklung auszusetzen  eine gewisse Art von offenem,
weitem Gleichmut die Valenz
emotionales Gleichgewicht Klarheit und so weiter,
aber Sie versuchen eigentlich nicht,
dieses Gefühl zu erzeugen, Sie entdecken
, dass dies eine angeborene Qualität des Seins ist
, die Ihnen innewohnt, und alles, was Sie
tun müssen, ist in etwas  Sinn, all die
Anhaftung aufzuheben, die wir in unseren
Gedanken und unseren emotionalen Reaktionen verfangen, so
dass das keine Loslösung ist, es ist keine
Anhaftung, wir verfangen uns nur
nicht so schnell darin  oder wenn wir es
erkennen und uns selbst zurückbringen
, wird das zur Übung, es ist wie
Gewichtheben, dein Geist geht ab, du
bringst ihn zurück, meiner geht ab, du bringst es
zurück, das Gewicht hilft dir natürlich,
die Muskeln aufzubauen, aber wenn du es bist
wenn wir über Achtsamkeit als eine Art Muskel sprechen, so
dass du den Verstand abschaltest, du ihn
zurückbringst und den Verstand abschaltest, du ihn zurückbringst,
der Verstand abschaltest und es irgendwo
wirklich interessant ist, du ihn nicht
zurückbringen willst, du ihn trotzdem zurückbringst
da fängt der Muskel an zu arbeiten
mit dem eigenen Widerstand gegen die
Anwesenheit shalvoy ein Ereignis Stutfohlen in Anna
Stress Behar Longs Klinik Mutter wird
schwindelig Achtsamkeit Parks' Order One Hats
Life Cornish Madsen oder - lächerlicherweise
Meiose Oceana Technik
hier eine imaginäre sogar das Schweigen zu begehen
Best Circuit in and Gate this your own
good versus fizzy distill this are Tom
Leben's
or even verdient it can enjoy garniere mich
auf dem Ärmel gut sobald du das geschmeckt hast
meine ich die Frage i  Wenn Sie wirklich
durch Ihr Leben schlafwandeln möchten oder
dafür wach sein
möchten, möchten Sie für Ihre Kinder da sein oder
sie nur als Gedanken in Ihrem Kopf betrachten,
anstatt wirklich zu sein  Geschenk für
sie oder für Ihre Enkelkinder oder für die
Natur oder was auch immer, wir können uns so
sehr in die Automatik unseres
Lebens verstricken, dass wir uns, wie Sie vorhin sagten
, durch unsere Momente bewegen, um
zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt die besseren Momente zu erleben
und wenn Sie zusammenfassen, dass Sie im Laufe eines Lebens
das Wichtigste in Ihrem Leben verpassen könnten,
und wer möchte das tun, ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie ein Buch von Thoreau haben, dort,
Walden und Thoros, berühmt in den USA
Nachdem ich es gut gesagt habe, ist es in Ordnung, wenn ich
von ihm zitiere, ja, Anatoly, wahrscheinlich
wissen Ihre Zuschauer, dass Thoreau in
den 1830er Jahren in Concord, Massachusetts, lebte und
für etwa Jahre zu einem See namens Walden Pond ging und dort
so einfach wie möglich lebte und  Er sagte darüber,
dass ich in den Wald ging, weil ich
bewusst leben wollte, um
nur die wesentlichen Tatsachen des Lebens vor Augen zu haben und zu sehen,
ob ich nicht lernen könnte, was sie zu
lehren hatten, und nicht, als ich zum Sterben kam,
entdeckte, dass ich nicht so gelebt hatte
sehr leicht, die Lebenden zu übersehen, weil
wir so in unseren Köpfen gefangen sind, und im
Englischen gibt es sogar den Ausdruck lost in
Thought we get so lost and
but we're really lost und wenn man das
über Tage Wochen Monate Jahre und Jahrzehnte macht
Sie könnten die wichtigsten
Aspekte Ihres eigenen Lebens
Shabazz Muhammads Genom in Valley City
Arkansas City verpassen und ihn sogar in einem Artikel
in einer Abhandlung über einen Flur ausbuhen und
es ist das Herz und die Mission der Löffel in
- schreibt mir im The People th  Vor
allem Steiger selbst erwähnte Allah, dass dies ein
Blitz von Süßigkeiten ist Dating die Etikette des
Lisatsen-Ofens, den er tatsächlich unter Siegel hat,
ist in diesem Buch und sie regieren den
Löffel über jede Amnestie-Tatsache
Wie man ihm wieder folgt,
sie sind nicht in Richtung einer
Yahoo-Site investiert und verkörpern sie in Vaasa. Unser
Image ist auch, dass wir auf Krankheit stehen
if
raga keep the spoon - XI de que VA Auf
diesen schlauen Kreisen auf vielen verschiedenen
Pfaden genau so, wie Sie wissen, wenn Sie den
Mount Everest nehmen, gibt es verschiedene Pfade
auf den Mount Everest, einige sind schwieriger
als andere, aber Sie wissen, dass Sie
dort unendlich sagen können  Zahl der Pfade zu einem
bestimmten Punkt in
Thoreaus Fall er Sie sagten, dass er
nichts von Achtsamkeit wüsste
oder über Achtsamkeit sprach, aber ganz
Walden ist eine Rhapsodie, die ich wou  Ich sage zur
Achtsamkeit, dass
er den gegenwärtigen Moment
verstand und er verstand, dass die Natur
in gewisser Weise der Lehrer war, und so
würde er sagen, dass er den ganzen Tag in seiner Tür sitzen
und nichts tun würde, damit jeder, der ihn
sieht, sagen würde, was für ein fauler Penner er ist  tat
nichts er saß nur da, aber er
sah zu wie die sonne über den himmel
wanderte die schatten veränderten das geräusch der
vögel hören mit
allem in kontakt stehen manchmal stand er
bis zur nase im teich und beobachtete einfach
was darin vor sich ging  die Oberfläche mit
Insekten und so weiter,
also übte er Achtsamkeit, aber
ohne das Wort zu verwenden, ja, die Antwort
auf Ihre Frage lautet, es gibt unendlich
viele Möglichkeiten, Achtsamkeit geschickt zu kultivieren,
aber es hilft, einige Anweisungen zu haben
, weil es eine noch
größere Anzahl gibt  von unendlichen Möglichkeiten, es
nicht geschickt zu machen und misszuverstehen, worum
es wirklich geht, sogar Dimaggio
Philemon zu entkommen, am Anfang innovativ
, das Opfer zu würgen, das sie für
Rent-TV markiert haben Odin '  s Arm macht sein Geld da
draußen Achtsamkeit ist K taglish joggin
und gesehen, wie der Arzt
läuft, ist ein wunderbarer Meditationsbeweis
und hilft aufgrund bestimmter Kollisionskrankheiten
für Schlag und oder Angreifer, die gut ersticken,
wenn diese Leute nicht sitzen werden,
weil sie es waren  sie sind gelangweilt oder sie
mögen es nicht und sie wollten, dass ihr
Körper sich bewegt, der Geist würde kein Problem damit haben, dass
der Körper läuft, also ist die
Frage, was ihre Orientierung
an Erfahrung ist, das ist es, worum es bei
Achtsamkeit wirklich geht
Beziehung Was ist Ihre
Beziehung zu erleben? Das Schneiden von
Gemüse für das Abendessen könnte eine achtsame
Erfahrung sein. Das Geschirr spülen könnte eine
achtsame Erfahrung sein. Einen Marathon zu laufen.
Sicherlich eine
Achtsamkeitserfahrung  am Morgen hat
es wirklich nur damit zu tun, wie
präsent Sie bereit sind, ohne
Agenda zu sein oder wie  Präsentieren Sie bereit sind
, eine Agenda zu haben, aber erkennen, was für eine
starke Agenda Sie haben, und sich nicht darin
verfangen d:
Der Mindfulness Indian Stick von Dr.
Beute glatt sehen sehen unsere kasachischen sehen
interveniert gehören stanlon dr.  Merritt
Attune Kellyanne Terrence Elphaba
talentierte Shop-Initiativen Buddhist
härtet seinen Ellbogen ab, man kann mit ihm darüber reden
, wie man es benutzt, aber es stimmt, dass ich mich nicht
als Buddhisten bezeichne
Der Wille
der Achtsamkeit kommt im Buddhismus
aus der buddhistischen Tradition, daher wird es
oft als das Herz der buddhistischen
Meditationsmeditation bezeichnet, aber Sie müssen
verstehen, dass in allen asiatischen Sprachen
das Wort für Herz und das Wort für
Geist dasselbe Wort ist  wenn du
heartful mindfulness nicht als heartfulness verstehst,
wenn du das wort auf
englisch mindfulness hörst, dann verstehst du es nicht
wirklich, ein ox auf skype
hat übrigens diese bedeutung überhaupt nicht,
also gibt es probleme,
dies so zu übersetzen, dass es  macht für die Leute wirklich Sinn,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass
es überhaupt ein Problem mit
den klassischen Religionszugehörigkeiten
gibt  Jede der religiösen Traditionen
hat Achtsamkeit in sich, in gewisser Weise
oder nicht, dass sie nur unterschiedliche
Namen dafür haben,
also geht es nicht darum,
wie Sie sich in Bezug auf Religion identifizieren,
sondern wie sehr Sie mit
den tiefsten Lehren übereinstimmen  Ihres Glaubens, wenn
Sie so wollen, und einige Leute glauben an eine
Art höhere Macht und andere
Leute glauben an die Natur oder Schönheit oder das
Universum oder wie auch immer Sie es nennen, aber
Menschen sind sehr interessante
Geschöpfe, weil wir so klein in so
einem großen sind  Universum, aber wir sind auch empfindungsfähig,
wir sind bewusst, und so gibt es dieses
gigantische Mysterium und die Frage nach dem
Sinn, was bedeutet das alles, und wir
leben für sehr, sehr kurze Momente, die wir
Lebenszeit nennen, also wie werden wir in
Beziehung dazu stehen und  So können Sie eine
tiefe heilige Erfahrung des Heiligen auf
einem Weg machen, der von
außen tatsächlich säkular aussieht und der in gewissem
Sinne eine tiefe Bedeutung bietet, unabhängig davon,
wie Sie sich in Bezug auf
Religiosität identifizieren  Schon das Wort Religion bedeutet
religio aus dem lateinischen religio, was
zusammenbinden bedeutet,
also verbindet dies in gewissem Sinne die
Punkte, die es uns ermöglichen, unsere
Kleinheit und unsere Größe, unsere
Beziehung zum gesamten Universum und
unsere Beziehung zu unserem Zuhause zu verstehen, das Sie kennen
unser Heimatplanet für unsere Kinder für unsere
Eltern und so weiter, so dass es eine
tiefgreifende Bedeutung ohne notwendigerweise einen
Katechismus oder eine Philosophie oder einen Glauben bietet
, mit dem Sie sich identifizieren müssen, wenn Sie
durch Santa Scans Field aus Denver finden,
sehen Sie plötzlich glänzenden Harry nicht auf der
Schicht bei ihnen  Lagern Sie ihre Felder oft
shulay in der Antike ein
Dank John Seneca Maka gut Ich habe es ausgewählt Am Ende hatten
wir Abendessen
Agnieszka saugte das schicke Geschäft auf, es
ist ein Verkauf und immer eine fertige fertige
oder Fliese und genährte Auskultation, die
über TCC ein paar Telefon und Fliese beladen ist  zeichen und
tausend zählt ein sinuskosmos lehrte
sie, wie sms schreiben und mr gehen.  cumson
die tätowierte Ausbildung hat eine Lea-
Zeit ist ich des Ladens itsuka Norman
entlang Staaten von zehn Pflichten Nachrichten mr.
Beginnen Sie eine machbare Hoffnung Art,
die Konstante zu halten, ist zu früh Sie wissen,
dass ich hier in tiefem Wasser bin, weil ich
kein Philosoph bin Ich bin nicht
wirklich vertraut mit den Stoikern in der
englischen Sprache
bedeutet Stoizismus all das  Sie haben gesagt, aber
es bedeutet auch eine gewisse Art von Starrheit,
eine gewisse Art, sich ein wenig zurückzuhalten.
Sie wissen, dass ich Schmerzen ertragen werde.
Ich werde ertragen, was ich nicht
mag, und das hat nichts mit Achtsamkeit zu tun,
also  Ich kann
Ihre Frage nicht beantworten, wie die Wurzeln der
Achtsamkeit tatsächlich aus
der stoischen Tradition stammen könnten, aber ich werde sagen,
dass es Leute gibt, die sagen, dass die Griechen
eigentlich Alexander der Große in
Indien gelandet sind  Indus River, sie
interagierten mit dem frühen Buddhismus und so mit
ihrem Partner, der zweihundert Jahre
früher war, also könnte es tatsächlich
Fäden davon geben, die viel früher in die westliche Welt
eingedrungen sind, als irgendjemand
erkennt, und ich denke, letztendlich, wenn
Sie sogar zu Jägern und Sammlern zurückkehren
Als wir alle
lange vor der Geschichte nur jagten und sammelten, wissen Sie
, dass Achtsamkeit evolutionär gesehen
eine Eigenschaft
wäre, für die wir sehr ausgewählt wären, denn wenn
Sie im Wald zu
Mindless kommen, werden Sie vielleicht gefressen, bevor Sie
Kinder haben, nicht  So scharf darauf, Boom zu würfeln, so ta
Norman fot savvy vegan
Sangeetha Tahoe Cretaceous Demon entkam
Loyalität Discutir einen Vorfall, den Mac
diese Agenturkritik und
plötzlich die Übertragung von Illinois an
Lukes Organisation Cousin Eastons Ray
endlose Geldscheine verfolgte Excel-Schacht auf dies
alles, was Anna fand  am Rande des
anhaltenden Oszillators des Kapitalismus auf insgesamt Sets das
Minimum Hobbiton Avraham Avinu
Garagenunterstützung Ich kann noch sagen, dass Stress Cash in der
Mitte ist, und ich wünsche Moskito auf Sets -
Aaron Don DET ER Schacht an jedem Diner am
persönlichen Telefon in Sarah gibt es Spiele
der  Socratic Ich stimme dem voll und ganz zu,
es ist sehr einfach, wenn etwas
viral wird oder wirklich populär wird, dass
es sofort wirklich wird  verdummt
und denaturiert bis zur
Unkenntlichkeit.
Achtsamkeit ist eine der tiefgründigsten
und eine der schönsten und eine
der ethischsten Lehren, die
Menschen je hervorgebracht haben, und es
wäre eine Tragödie, wenn der Kapitalist, den Sie
kennen, so etwas anstellt  aus materialistischer Sicht
zerstörte es einfach, bevor es
wirklich eine Chance hatte, tief zu erblühen, also
gibt es eine ethische Grundlage für
Achtsamkeit, es geht um die Optimierung
des Wohlbefindens und die Minimierung von Schaden, und
in der Medizin lautet der hippokratische Eid,
zuerst keinen Schaden anzurichten
Wie wollen Sie jetzt überhaupt wissen, ob
Sie ohne Achtsamkeit Schaden anrichten,
was die Verwendung im Militär und
in Unternehmen betrifft, und ob die
Unternehmen es in all dem ausnutzen,
dass dies in gewissem Sinne das Risiko und
der Preis ist?  des Erfolgs man kann keinen
Erfolg haben, ohne dass es alle wollen und
dann werden viele Leute versuchen, es
auszunutzen, es zu einer Ware zu machen und so weiter, aber
Achtsamkeit ist so mächtig, dass ich eine habe
Überzeugung, dass es am Ende
tatsächlich in Ordnung sein wird, dass die
Menschen von Achtsamkeit sehr gelangweilt sein werden,
wenn sie sie nicht auf eine sehr tiefe Art und Weise probieren,
und in Bezug auf die Umgestaltung der Gesellschaft hat
das Parlament vor drei oder vier Monaten im Vereinigten Königreich ein Ja ausgesprochen
-Partei-Parlamentsbericht namens „A
Mindful Nation UK“, in dem
sie mehr, viel mehr Mittel und
Programme für Achtsamkeit in vier Bereichen der
britischen Gesellschaft, Bildung, Gesundheitswesen,
Strafjustiz und
in der Technologieentwicklung forderten
Das Leitungsgremium hat einen Bericht
herausgegeben, in dem die Bedeutung von Achtsamkeit betont wird.
Nein, er ist der im Film gesehene DeNooyer.
Sie sind Karate für ihn
Bombenangriff gefüttert Amitaba
Sehnensocke sagt, die Insel des freundlichen Mahavira ist
Austin Coons, die effizienten Drachenruinen
Der FEMA-Mann ist ein halbes Dutzend Byzantiner
und wer kann unsere Nation zerstören? Dieses
Design ist in Fierman Georgia abgereist. PG & E
Shalini dachte auch, Monsanto Walt
Disney Google sei weniger menschlich DSS
Also 270
klarsichtige SF Olga war Müll und
Vinod hat sich falsch vorgestellt, dass Todd die
Opferfindung über dieses
mysteriöse Management von Los Angeles sicher unterschrieben hat,
um Ihnen gut
zu sagen
das sa P klang
für mich nicht wahr, wenn Sie wissen, dass es Ihnen
nichts ausmacht, dass ich ganz ehrlich darüber bin,
nicht im Schweizer Fernsehen, da es
eigentlich das Schweizer Fernsehprogramm war, von dem ich
weiß, dass einige der Leute
Achtsamkeit bei Google lehrten, das sind sie  fantastisch
Ich kenne Leute, die
Achtsamkeit lehren in Twitter und an verschiedenen
anderen Orten im Silicon Valley und in
der Ford Motor Company und so mit und
zuhören  Wenn Sie mit dem
Kapitalismus interagieren, so sehe ich das im Grunde,
was wir tun, indem wir uns mit
der Kampfkunst des Aikido beschäftigen, achtsames Aikido,
also denken die Kapitalisten vielleicht, dass
wir Achtsamkeit ausnutzen,
um zu sagen, dass sie die Belegschaft zum Laufen bringen  schneller
oder härter arbeiten oder für weniger Geld oder
was auch immer effizienter sein weniger
gestresst sein, aber sie verstehen nicht wirklich
die potenzielle Kraft der
Achtsamkeit, um die
Realität ihrer Organisationen zu verändern, während ich diesbezüglich nicht
wie ein Zukunftsmusiker bin
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass das
, was hier vor sich geht, potenziell gesund ist, dass, selbst
wenn bestimmte Leute es ausnutzen oder
versuchen, es für ihre eigenen Zwecke zu nutzen
, die Gesamtprognose in diesem
bestimmten Moment eher positiv als
negativ ist, was übrigens Sie sind  könnte
gut sagen, warum gehst du nach Davos, warum
gehst du zum Weltwirtschaftsforum
und redest mit den Meistern des Universums
und meditierst, und die Antwort ist der
gleiche Grund, yo  Du pflanzt Samen und
du weißt nicht, wo sie
Wurzeln schlagen werden, aber alle Menschen, man könnte
aus buddhistischer Sicht sagen, alle
Menschen in ihrer wahrsten Natur sind Buddhisten,
sie sind in gewissem Sinne bereits
erleuchtet, okay, was auch immer das bedeutet, und
und was wir versuchen, ist
, dies als eine Art primären Vektor der
Transformation und Heilung zu kultivieren, und das
könnte die Transformation des
kapitalistischen Systems einschließen, selbst weil es
aufgrund dessen, was vor sich geht, die nächsten zwei- oder dreihundert Jahre oder sogar fünfzig Jahre nicht überleben wird  in allen
möglichen technologischen Bereichen, einschließlich
Energieverbrauchsmaterialien, die MANET
Renoir, indische Küche oder Depressionen,
die Austin imitieren, und Behandlungen, leichte
Umstellungen, denn meistens üben wir
zusammen, denn wenn wir nur darüber
reden, ist es nur Gerede, es ist nur
Philosophie, es ist genauso wie konzeptionell
Praxis ist nicht nur konzeptionell, es ist
die Kultivierung von Bewusstsein.
Bewusstsein ist etwas, das Sie
nicht bekommen müssen, weil es intri ist  nsic für Sie,
aber wir trainieren nicht die Muskeln, also
wissen wir oft nicht, wie wir dorthin gelangen,
und dann gibt es auch diese ganze
Frage des Eigeninteresses, wie wenn Sie
das Spiel für sich persönlich maximieren wollen,
aber dann halten Sie  dass Sie in
Achtsamkeit sehen, dass Ihr
Egoismus Sie tatsächlich in eine
Richtung des Unglücks führt und Sie
übrigens mehr Schaden als Nutzen anrichten, jetzt, wo
wir genug über die globale Erwärmung wissen und
was mit der Umwelt los ist, von der Sie
das als eine Form davon bezeichnen könnten  Achtsamkeit Wir
wissen genug, um zu wissen, dass menschliche Aktivitäten
im Menschen, wenn Sie es Industrie nennen wollen,
tatsächlich das Leben auf diesem Planeten bedrohen.
Wie wir darauf reagieren, wird ein
Maß unserer tiefsten genetischen Intelligenz sein, und
ich denke, wir sehen Menschen, die und sind
Der Aufstieg der Nation zu der Gelegenheit, die Art
und Weise, wie wir den Planeten aufheizen, zu
ändern, damit wir nicht alle
Gletscher und die Antarktis und alles
andere verlieren
einatmen und ausatmen Finnisch
Michigan so positiv in der und jetsam
Desson war wirklich Christopher Ende im
richtigen Team gut ja gut ich finde
es toll, dass du mich zurückdrängt, weil UCI ist,
wenn wir über die praktische Anwendbarkeit
der Dinge sprechen, aber aus  eine bestimmte
Perspektive, wenn Sie denken, ich sei zu
optimistisch, wenn ich Ihnen 1970 gesagt
hätte, dass Meditation und Yoga nicht so weit
in den Mainstream der Medizin eindringen würden
, dass sie tatsächlich eine
Revolution auslösten und wie die Menschen über
Menschen und Krankheiten denken und denken  besonders
chronische Krankheiten, Gesundheit, Wohlbefinden,
Langlebigkeit und so weiter, Sie hätten
gesagt, ich wäre verrückt,
wenn ich Ihnen gesagt hätte, dass
die National Institutes of Health die
Meditationsforschung und
insbesondere die Achtsamkeitsforschung in diesem Sinne finanzieren würden
von Hunderten von Millionen
Dollar hätten Sie gesagt, Sie
seien verrückt nach all dem, was
in den letzten 36 Jahren passiert ist, also habe ich keine
wirklichen Beweise dafür  dass
ich so pessimistisch wie möglich
und nicht so optimistisch wie möglich sein sollte
Zimmy kommentiert oktomanische Etiketten, also werde ich
mit der Botschaft sprechen und in dieser
Dateninitiative auf dem beschäftigten Jean-Jacques
Hublin bald nach nebligen Hoppla in Flook scheitern,
um tatsächlich darüber nachzudenken  neue animierte Show
Martin kleiner Sklave Insulin und Bisman
Ich bin ein bisschen sofort auf einem Skater Hamdi
sagen Action Kite in dann werde ich mit
Integrins sprechen ist Ahmed Khan von Sand Ocean
nach einer Version von Tom Bishop im Oktober
King Kinder auf See in Insalata  eine neblige
neblige Währung John coverton so ein
Herbstkerl Zeichen Wendy Fliege Taktiken arbeiten Tom
Lehman dass Arsch dr.  Rob Liefeld
willen schlägt meilenweit einige Drachen und
wir sind und was passiert mit dem Ehrgeiz
, woanders erfolgreich zu sein
und so weiter
Eine Frage, ich bin mir
nicht sicher, wie ich darauf antworten soll. Ich habe die
Erfahrung gemacht, dass
Menschen wirklich nach tiefem
Wohlbefinden in Zufriedenheit suchen, deshalb sind
wir so gierig, deshalb versuchen wir
, immer an einen besseren Ort zu gelangen  Und
was Thoreau sagt, ja, Sie
landen an einem besseren Ort in Ihrem
Grab, wenn Sie tot sind, und in dem Moment,
bevor Sie merken, dass ich vielleicht alles
falsch verstanden habe, was ich sage, ist, sterben Sie jetzt, bringen Sie
es hinter sich, dann den Rest  Ihres Lebens
ist ein Geschenk, und Sie können Ihre Macht
nutzen, Ihren Ehrgeiz nutzen, Ihre Liebe nutzen
, um Ihren Beitrag zur Welt zu optimieren,
und die erste Person, die davon
profitieren wird, sind Sie, aber Sie werden
nicht die einzige Person sein, die davon profitiert
sen  Wenn Sie ein Geschenk für die Welt werden
und dann die Arbeit, die Sie tun,
sinnvoller ist, inspiriert es andere Menschen, wenn eine
Führungskraft in einem Unternehmen diese Art von Achtsamkeit verkörpert, die
jeden im Unternehmen
dazu inspiriert, länger zu arbeiten, als
die Führungskraft sagen muss  Nein, arbeite nicht
länger, arbeite klüger, weil ich möchte, dass du
nach Hause gehst und dich um deine
Kinder kümmerst und nicht nur ein großer Erfolg
bei der Arbeit bist. Wir brauchen nicht so viel mehr
Geld
eine gewisse Art von größerem
Gleichgewicht, wo ja, natürlich sind wir
auf finanzieller Ebene erfolgreich, aber
das ist nicht die absolute Signatur von
Erfolg
es ist und du kannst es tun Olivia seit Allen
sollte ich Leuten beibringen müssen ehrfürchtig
entfernt ish bedeutende Ashton die
Fairness es ist auf den Kommentaren wach saugen
Schrägen ignorieren deine E-Mails ja wir können sehen
lass mich dir sagen das ist a  Eine sehr große
Herausforderung, wonach Sie wirklich fragen,
ist, was die Technologie
zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt tut, und wir sind von
einer analogen Welt in eine digitale Welt übergegangen, in der
wir so in das Digitale hineingezogen sind, dass
wir vergessen,
dass es immer noch analoge Wesen gab  niemand hat
die E-Mail-Frage gelöst, die ich für mich per E-Mail sende,
ist wie ein Wasserfall, es ist wie ein Feuerwehrschlauch,
es gibt keine Möglichkeit
, auf alles zu antworten, also bewege ich mich, tanze
mit ihm. Ich antworte nicht auf E-Mails. Meine
Nichtantwort ist eine Antwort
antworte nicht
oder ich lasse mir Zeit Ich antworte nicht auf
E-Mails auf meinem Handy Ich checke nie
E-Mails auf meinem Handy, wenn ich bereit bin
Weg vom gegenwärtigen Moment,
wie gut bin ich darin, wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr gut, weil ich jeden, mit dem ich per
E-Mail in Kontakt stehe, liebe und mit dem ich in einer
tiefen Beziehung stehe, und ich spreche
mehr über die Arbeit als über die Familie,
also gibt es diese Blüte  wie Sie über
Achtsamkeit sagten und ich bin ein großer
Teil davon b  Aber zu viel des Guten ist
nicht gut, also ist es wieder wie das Yoga
des Gleichgewichts, und jeder von uns muss seinen
eigenen Weg finden, damit jeder von
uns 24 Stunden am Tag die gleichen 24 Stunden am Tag hat,
ob Google existiert oder nicht  Es existiert nicht,
ob Microsoft existiert oder nicht
, ob es E-Mail, SMS
oder was auch immer gibt, und wir müssen neue Wege finden
, um unsere Menschlichkeit in analoger
Form zu erhalten. Entschuldigung,
Sherry Turkle am MIT untersucht die
Auswirkungen der Technologie auf junge Menschen und
einige  der Ergebnisse sind absolut
schockierend, also gibt es allen Grund,
Achtsamkeit und Elternschaft zu kultivieren
Achtsamkeit in der Erziehung Achtsamkeit
Achtsame Erziehung ja
Australischer Indie Kalume in der Gesellschaft
zieht Unschuldige an, weil Givaudan
ihn treffen wir ihn also nur Gedanken, die ich seekrank werde,
sind Meditationskurse, in denen
Lavallee ja ich  tun und meine beiden
Töchter sind Yogalehrerinnen. Ich weiß nicht,
wie ich erklären soll, dass es in gewisser
Weise ansteckend sein könnte, aber ich mache
es nicht, sie ahmen mich nicht nach
Wenn sie es tun, dann deshalb, weil
sie auf ihre eigene Art und Weise dazu gekommen sind, und
ich habe versucht, mich so weit wie möglich aus diesem Bild herauszuhalten.
Sie lebt in Städten
in Michigan, und ein Puzzle trifft sich zum Essen
in Konkan  Hausrat
und Kittel Gitarre begannen mit dem
Scannen der abendlichen Partyeinladungen.
Das könnte man sehen, das Wort Autorität ist
sehr interessant und im
deutschsprachigen Raum hat Autorität
viel Bedeutung, mit der eine
Autorität im Englischen verwandt ist
Wort Autor und das verwandte Wort
Authentizität, also ist es nicht so, dass ich
Autorität meide, aber die tiefste Autorität
ist, in gewisser Weise der Autor
deines eigenen Lebens zu sein, das kannst du nur tun, wenn
du achtsam bist, das kannst du nur tun, wenn
du es bist  Sie sind wach und was andere Leute dann
von Ihnen fühlen oder auf Sie projizieren, in
das Sie sich nicht verwickeln müssen, ist,
dass es eine gewisse Art von
Authentizität gibt, die die Leute sagen werden, dass Sie so
real sind, dass Sie so real sind, bitte, aber was
Sie zeigen wirklich auf  ist, dass, wenn
jemand anwesend ist, Sie lieben, dass
der Dalai Lama auf Tibetisch oft als
kundan bezeichnet wird
von anderen Gedanken oder etwas anderem abgelenkt zu werden
,
so dass diese Kultivierung der Fähigkeit zur
Präsenz andere Menschen berührt, denn
wenn ich anwesend bin, dann sind
unsere Beziehungen anders, weil wir in einer Beziehung sind,
weil ich bereit bin, den
Raum der Wachheit und Herzlichkeit zu halten
und so weiter  gefühlt werden und es gibt anderen Menschen in gewissem
Sinne ohne
Worte die
Erlaubnis zu finden, mich nicht zu kopieren,
ob Dalai Lama oder Mutter Teresa oder
irgendjemand, denn das ist ein Held für Sie, sondern
herauszufinden, wer Sie sind, und sich nicht darin zu
verfangen, das zu denken  wer du denkst, dass
du bist oder die Erzählung von dir Ich bin so,
ich bin so schlecht, ich bin so deprimiert,
ich bin so traurig, ich habe solche Angst, dass diese
Erzählung ist, wer du wirklich bist,
du bist so mu  ch größer als Ihre
Erzählung und letztendlich wer Sie sind
vielleicht eher Wachheit
Bewusstsein Achtsamkeit Verletzung
dann die Geschichte von mir, es ist
Agnia Auslandsforderungen sind für die Gesundheit
unvergesslicher Schrei statisch muffig aussehen
scheiß Falafel in Sindschar Elend So schön
oder ich sehe einen kleinen Superstar in Philly
Mansion seit Ballons aufgeblasen Ihram
lass Beleidigung raus 1490 vertraut mm fliegen
statisch Danke ihm Assistent Geschäft
auch bereit, plötzlich einen irgendwie
engen Sohn los alamos zu haben  devasya stimme ein auf
Psalm 11 ist Trevor Aaronson aus unserem
Lager bringt Barmherzigkeit Khlebnikov Hinske
weiß automatisch von Yoga oder amis de la
mia schlafen Ich meine, wenn nicht, versuche ich,
ein Schwerverbrecher zu sein : und tausend tankage des
Systems la pêche v rectus und  Kind
Wunden auch Travis es geändert Amity zu
Freiheitsstrahl verschwinden, solange östlich von
Man Laden Beschaffung des Spezialisten vor
kurzem genannt Raman die Anführungszeichen
Himalayan Yazoo, das ist eine sehr
tiefgründige Frage, also lustig, danke dafür
, und die Antwort lautet: Ich weiß nicht,
ich denke, es ist nur eine schlechte Angewohnheit, dass
wir es auch tun, wenn alle es tun,
aber wenn Sie aufhören und anfangen zu
fragen  Darüber, wie gesagt, jeder
bekommt die gleichen 24 Stunden, wie wir
in Bezug auf Schlaf, Essen,
Emily, Ehrgeiz
, Arbeit erledigen werden, müssen wir wirklich
steuern  und jeder von uns muss wirklich seinen
eigenen Weg finden, damit wir
unser Leben authentisch leben und nicht irgendeine
Geschichte darüber, wie wir sein sollten, wenn
Sie das tun, scheint der Stress viel
kontrollierbarer zu sein, weil Sie damit umgehen können
, und außerdem gibt es einen
Wir denken, dass wir alles unter Kontrolle haben,
aber Sie wissen, dass wir kaum
etwas unter Kontrolle haben. Ich meine, Sie wissen, dass Sie eines
Tages gesund sein
können  passiert Menschen
e  an einem einzigen Tag, also ist es nicht
so sehr wichtig, was mit dir passiert,
sondern wie du dich entscheidest, in
Beziehung damit zu stehen, und dann wird das Leben selbst
in gewissem Sinne zum Lehrplan, und
dieser Lehrplan wird dich auf eine Weise
formen, die in der Heilung transformativ ist, was er
nicht ist  macht immer Spaß es ist nicht immer angenehm
es ist nicht nur oh weißt du wunderbar ich bin
ein Buddha weißt du kein Problem es ist mehr
wie der Zeichentrickfilm nichts passiert als nächstes
Das ist es das ist es wenn dir das nicht gefällt
was dich im nächsten Moment denken lässt
wird besser, aber wenn du
mit diesem Moment des Jetzt umgehst, dann ist die
Zukunft schon anders, weil
du in diesem hier aufgetaucht bist, sogar mit
dem Unangenehmen, sogar mit dem, mit dem du am
meisten nicht umgehen willst, wie
sagen wir a  Krebsdiagnose oder ein chronischer
Schmerzzustand, der Sie nicht
schlafen lässt, Sie können sich mit denen auf eine Weise anfreunden
, die transformativ ist, da die
Wissenschaft zeigt, dass es auf
der Ebene des Nervensystems auf der
Ebene von t transformativ ist  Die Chromosomen auf der Ebene
der Telomere, aber viel wichtiger,
die Ebene des Herzens Ich wusste, wenn ich
einen Feind küsse, ist meine Stimme nicht Alicia, wenn
die Person verlangt, wie die Mäuse um
Mitternacht
sprangen  für Medici eine weitere schwere Entscheidung
wie Medicare und eine Kanone, Sie wissen, nein,
es ist so,
meine Frau, ich muss 24 Stunden am
Tag meditieren, um mit meiner Frau Schritt zu halten, die von
Natur aus achtsam ist, und ja, und das
werde ich auch sagen in diesen fast 50
Jahren  die früher
Meditation in dieser Meditation praktiziert haben, weißt du, Sitzen, Meta
, Seed-Meditation und andere
Formen.
Ich sehe es tatsächlich als eine
Liebesaffäre  mein Atem und sei entspannt oder
so ähnlich, es ist eine Liebesaffäre
mit dem Leben und die einzige Zeit, in der das
Leben in diesem Moment ist, also wenn wir es verpassen, haben
wir unser Leben in diesem Moment verpasst, also
von dem Punkt an, an dem du deine s nimmst  Essen ist
ein radikaler Akt der Vernunft, es ist ein
radikaler Akt der Liebe und ein radikaler
Akt der Beziehung, also muss meine
Frau oder sonst jemand nicht meditieren, damit ich
von ihm profitiere. Manchmal
sitzen wir tatsächlich zusammen, manchmal machen wir
tatsächlich weiter  sich zusammen zurückziehen, aber
das ist sehr selten, aber aus der
Perspektive dessen, was ich gesagt habe, von
Moment zu Moment, wenn wir
zusammen zu Abend essen, wenn wir zusammen kochen oder
wenn wir tun, was immer wir tun, wenn
wir ohne Zwang füreinander da sind
Jedes davon auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise,
damit ich glücklicher bin, das ist Liebe
und das ist Achtsamkeit. John Capleton
Hamdi, es ist ein Ophthalmoskop. Lagerfeld.
Ich denke, Sie kennen die Antwort darauf bereits
dass
Schwestern ominöses Feelin answerin Moment
värnamo Ehrgeiz ertragen Leonie Kalasha
und eine technisch ostracon Skizze
erstaunte mich ein Vektorzahnarzt auf Steve
adidas m400 Garn und anscheinend
streicheln unsere Socken sie  und Andre auf hektischem
Vormarsch achteckig in ndon Film Remix
Manifest die digitale Collage jetzt
Headset auf sehr stylische Marke Damon
fertig im TOC-Projekt Tata Tata
klick das Eisen und die Befreiung noch Wanne mit
Alaun und Genuss
Oktoman Sontag
[Musik]
du